rarely have events at number 10 face
this much scrutiny the country is
watching waiting speculating on the
consequences of alleged rule breaking by
those in power
mps have been clamoring for a full
publication of the internal inquiry into
potential breaches of the rules compiled
by senior civil servant sue gray that
this government can be trusted to
deliver
the results of which if harmful enough
could lead to the collapse of boris
johnson's leadership but with
anticipation at its peak now london's
metropolitan police who've stepped in to
carry out their own criminal
investigation have put the brakes on
calling for the report to make minimal
reference to the events they're
examining to avoid prejudicing the case
the demand means the much-awaited sugree
report will be limited excluding details
of the most serious breaches including
possible errors by the police guarding
downing street
i think the net police have got
something to answer for here this
leading lawyer who previously defended
wikileaks founder julian assange
believes the met police isn't capable of
a fair investigation i think there's
real
uh question marks around the credibility
of the met police investigating their
own officers who didn't prevent crimes
and did not report crimes uh and i think
they have a duty now to bring in an
independent police force
to look and review
what it was that the met didn't do
so what did happen at number 10 during
the pandemic it's believed that 17
gatherings ranging from cheese and wine
events to boozy leaving dues happened
between may 2020 and april 2021 across
whitehall with sue gray looking into
many of them
meanwhile london's metropolitan police
have launched a separate criminal
investigation into eight of the most
serious breaches of covid lockdown rules
behind the door of the country's most
famous address boris johnson's planning
his next move
all of this means that like the hands of
the newly renovated but not yet working
famous clock politics in westminster is
at a standstill boris johnson in a
perpetual state of high noon his
opponent in a continuous midnight still
in the dark about exactly what went on
behind the doors of number 10. it also
means that any momentum opponents of
boris johnson may have gained in recent
weeks subsides giving johnson room to
maneuver
it's unclear when the police will
conclude their criminal investigation
the results of that could be serious for
johnson but might be months away
in the meantime speculation over parties
at number 10 continues but there is of
course one downing street night owl and
potential star witness neither sue gray
nor the police can question
neve barker al jazeera westminster